with everything from superhero team ups
to record-breaking horror releases 2017
has been a big year for movies and an
even bigger year for all the Easter eggs
they had it's a lot to go through so we
rounded up some of the all-time best
movie Easter eggs of 2017 some spoilers
ahead a muffin a beer the fifth entry in
the Pirates of the Caribbean franchise
have featured a heavily CGI version of a
younger Johnny Depp as Captain Jack
Sparrow but that wasn't the only glimpse
into the actors passed just before
Sparrow is set to be executed his uncle
Jack played by ex Beatle Paul McCartney
tells him a joke it sounds like your
average bad pirate joke but it's
actually an easter egg with roots 20
years in the past that started with Al
Pacino of all people while defin Pacino
were filming 1997's Donnie Brasco Pacino
would tell that joke repeatedly then
laugh and walk off Depp later admitted I
didn't get the joke he thought it was my
problem he inflicted it upon me and I
could feel my IQ points drop he would
howl every time he told the joke what
better way to return the favor than to
inflict it on millions of moviegoers
even better the guy laughing at the joke
in Pirates of the Caribbean sounds a lot
like Pacino
[Laughter]
playtime hot on the heels of 2016 s
Deadpool Logan proved once again that
it's OK for a superhero to spill buckets
of blood and swell like a sailor without
sacrificing those ever important ticket
sales hopefully this will kick off a new
trend in superhero films but Logan
wasn't entirely focused on the future it
also has a few pretty sweet callbacks
today's of Wolverine past while the
comic books Laura picks up play a big
part in the plots you may not have
noticed another Easter egg that popped
up during a Logan's funeral you can see
one of the mutant children holding a
Wolverine action figure complete with
yellow spandex considering this as most
likely Hugh Jackman's last outing with
the adamantium claws it was a nice touch
to put Wolverines early comics outfit on
screen even if it only showed up briefly
and on a plastic toy journey mountain
director Jordan vogt-roberts is a
self-proclaimed video
game fanatic and his sophomore feature
film Kong Skull Island is jam-packed
with video game nods with references to
everything from Resident Evil to The
Legend of Zelda but the best Easter egg
in the film doesn't come from a massive
franchise rather it's a subtle nod to
journey a game in which players have to
cross a huge open world while
communicating with other players via
musical notes all while trying to reach
a glowing mountain in the distance
perhaps to emphasize the journey of the
characters in Kong had to take to cross
Skull Island vogt-roberts like a
recreation of journeys mountain in the
distance and a few scenes of the movie
it's most visible when the helicopters
first breached the storm around the
island and again at the ends when the
characters are leaving it's subtle but
awesome once you've spotted it a perfect
example of what an easter egg should be
musical cameo it's the music of baby
driver that brings a film to life which
is particularly fitting considering the
core premise has its origins in a music
video in 2002 Edgar Wright who helmed
baby driver directed a music video for
blue song by British band mint Royale
the narrative of the video is this a
sunglasses wearing driver takes a group
of thieves to a heist then waits in the
car and lip syncs to a song sound
familiar that sequence inspired the
opening scene in baby driver which sees
baby rocking out to bell-bottoms by John
Spencer Blues Explosion
while the rest of the crew pulls off the
heist even better
bright didn't pay homage to that video
and stale only during a scene in baby's
apartment the blues song a music video
completely be seen playing on the TV
spider signal you may have missed this
quick ease to reckon spider-man
homecoming because it was only visible
for about a second in the scene when
spider-man is locked in the warehouse in
DC he starts tinkering with a suit to
pass the time Oh what maybe we should
run that refresher course that's the
spider signal also known as the worst a
superhero gadget ever the spider signal
first appeared in the amazing spider-man
issue number 3 published in 1963 in
which the signal is literally nothing
more than a warning to criminals that
spider-man is somewhere nearby
usually surprise are the other end of
the beam of light protecting the signal
so why is this such a great easter egg
compared to everything else in
homecoming like the ultron head Spidey
pulls out of a bag later in the same
scene
mainly because it's such a useless
detail to add and it's all the more
amazing because of that final farewell
the guardians of the galaxy movies have
a ton of Easter eggs but one of the best
recurring eggs in the franchise showed
up at yondu's funeral one of your news
favorite trinkets in the first film was
a little blue crystal frog that he got
at the beginning of the movie I like to
stick them all in a roll on my control
console in guardians - just before yandi
was blasted into space the camera
lingers for a second on that same frog
sitting by his side it just as it did in
life among the hundreds of Easter eggs
and Marvel movies this is the only one
that will bring a tear to your eye
Walt's initials spotting secrets in any
Disney film is always fun and the studio
rarely disappoints in 2017 s live-action
Beauty and the Beast
one of the biggest Easter eggs in the
film is built right into the woodwork so
to speak in the beasts massive ornate
ballroom pay attention to the monogram
inscribed on the ballroom floor hidden
within the flowery design is a big WD
short for Walt Disney honestly which
caught this one up to a trick of the eye
of deceased erech hadn't been confirmed
by none other than Sarah Greenwood
production designer for the film book
whacked by every reasonable measure the
Tom Cruise led reboot of the mummy was a
complete failure
critics bashed the film for everything
from the muddled story to its shameless
ripoffs of previous plots but there was
one little highlights in the movie that
might warrant a rewatch maybe if you
hate yourself in the scene when dr
jekyll goes full-on hide Annabel
Wallace's character Jenny knocks a guy
out by whacking him on the head with a
big book look closely because that book
has made an on-screen appearance in the
past it's the book of the dead first
seen in 1999's The Mummy you know the
one with Brendan Fraser who would have
thought would ever miss that version
gunshot sonata John wick Chapter two
should be a case study for sequels done
right it took everything great about the
first film and made it even better a lot
of that comes down to the incredible
detail put into building the franchise's
hyperkinetic world details that most
fans likely won't even notice probably
the best example came at the end of John
wick - during the gun battle in the
museum the shootout is set to Vivaldi's
Four Seasons only the percussion is
replaced by the sound of wicks guns
literally turning his shots into the
musical score
it's an insanely obscure easter egg but
a fantastic example of an off kilter
detail that only the filmmakers are
likely to ever notice as director chats
to house key put it if somebody does
pick it up it'll be two guys going like
hooli that's Vivaldi what's in a name
we know ready player one isn't getting
released until 2018 but it's Easter eggs
are already spilling all over the film's
marketing when the film's logo was
released in July 2017 fans were quick to
spot an easter egg hiding right in the
name of the film if you look closely the
letters and ready player one for
mermaids that runs to a literal egg in
the center of the O in one as noted
bikers mode oh that's a nod to adventure
a 1979 Atari game that sees the player
moving through the maze like rooms of a
castle more importantly adventurers
widely believed to contain the first
Easter egg in gaming history and in the
ready player one book adventure is a
massive inspiration for one of the
characters we don't want to give too
much else away so you'll have to read
the book or wait until March 2018 to see
how all those pieces connect thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all the school stuff we know
your love to
[Music]